hi welcome to your brain boost my name
is Davis Jones from ezel this is ei ZL
it's an online school that is trying to
shake things up make things more
accessible and flexible and affordable
so that we can make the higher education
system ready for the 24 the future
basically yeah anyway I'm here with Alan
and Alan is a friend that I met in San
Francisco recently he is a
self-described polymath a futurist host
of simulation on YouTube where he
interviews all sorts of really
interesting people entrepreneurs and
scientists and he's really interested in
consciousness and neuroscience am I
getting that right Alan that I described
you accurately Davison such a pleasure
to be on easels brain boost today to
talk about this pressing issue and I'm
really happy to talk to you about it I
really respect you a lot what you're
building with you so let's do it
Thank You Alan and I appreciate that so
what are we gonna talk about today first
of all thank you for being here viewers
I see a few you guys are coming in note
that you can submit any comments that
you have related to the conversation in
the chat function in the livestream but
we're going to be talking about
attention economics today so I figured
that a good way to start the life frame
was to talk about what is attention
economics and so I got this definition
it's an approach to the management of
information that treats human attention
as a scarce commodity and applies
economic theory to solve various
information management problems
practically speaking what is the
attention economy the idea is basically
that we're in a world where there's so
much information that what is scarce is
not information but it's our attention
so this is basically saying that you
know we can we have limited attention
what do we do with it how is that
shaping our brains Alan do you
understand attention
economics to be anything different than
what I've described that's pretty damn
good another thing that I really think
is important is that it is
with the amount of people that now live
on the planet and the ability to
digitally in instantaneously send a
thought to the ecosystem that is the
internet now now there seems to be so
much information and that's messing with
the signal-to-noise ratio and a lot of
other stuff that talking about yeah
that's definitely a great concept to
start with the signal-to-noise ratio I
mean it is interesting when there is so
much information it's like what do you
focus on and that is really what we're
gonna be talking about today I think
actually a really fun way to start the
conversation is to use the same story
that James Williams talked about in his
book stand out of my light so I in the
description of the video you're gonna
see that we talk about James Williams
actually if you go on social media it
looks like we haven't put the links in
yet but if you go on mine or yours or
Twitter ezal Twitter any of the social
media links this brain boost was kind of
inspired by this guy James Williams
former Google executive I think he was
basically head of UI UX at Google and
he's written this book called stand out
of my light which basically argues that
we really need to think about how our
brains interact with technology and the
fascinating reason he calls his book
stand out of my light there's this
really cantankerous Greek philosopher
called Diogenes who apparently was kind
of crabby and Alexander the Great
actually really liked him and so
Alexander the Great came and visited do
do genies in his little hovel and said
is there anything I can do for you and
the guy said stand out of my ha so his
one wish accident of the Great was for
Alexander the Great to get out of his
sunlight
anyway the reason I think that relates
to attention economics is like what is
the Sun and I think James Williams
develops this a lot in his TED talk and
we'll add some links to the description
of the video later but you know in the
era of so much noise how do we determine
what we focus on have you thought about
this at all Allen like do you feel like
technology can distract us from things
that are meaningful things that are
productive yes absolutely
and another thing that
piggybacks on what you were describing
is this is the word time within this
attention economy that we're talking
about time being this most precious
thing that we have we only have two and
a half billion seconds on this planet or
twenty five thousand days and if you
install things like you've linked as
well Stanford University made their
habit lab and you can yeah you can go
and download the this program that helps
you it's chrome extension that helps you
make interventions like it should
literally start showing you the seconds
that you've been spending on YouTube or
Facebook or whatever social platform
you're on and then it really gives you a
better idea of exactly how much time
you're spending on that platform but
just yes I do think that technology and
social media can be used for good like
the positives of information sharing is
[ __ ] amazing the fact that you can
just get information about something
going on across the world really quickly
that's awesome but again with the whole
signal-to-noise ratio and it's
complicating things a little bit and we
need a we we need to figure out kind of
what's going on with kids as well when
they're they're dopaminergic system is
getting hijacked by things like
clickbait and advertisements and we
needed we needed psychometric profiling
all these different things that I would
love to talk to you about yeah tell me
about that phrase you just used was a
dopa metric processing your dopaminergic
hijacking your cholinergic hijacking
okay what the heck is it we have this
dopamine dopaminergic system really
easily kind of related to the
marshmallow experiment and the
marshmallow experience just a famous
experiment that was run where there were
there's kids that are given the option
to either eat a marshmallow right away
or have a delay if they if they hold
themselves off they can have it get two
marshmallows instead and snow and so
just general ideas if you're able to
delay your gratification just a little
longer which this is a good example for
doing something like folk
on your long-term goals so my long-term
goal might be to write a blog post or to
make a video you know write the
storyboard for the video all this
different stuff but my short-term
gratification might be I'm gonna go and
hit the lottery on Facebook and click
those notifications I'm gonna go and hit
the email lottery and go and open up all
those different emails and so for us to
be able to focus with this top-down
processing the prefrontal cortex
executive decision-making say I am going
to focus on my long-term goal I'm not
going to let my my phone's on silent I'm
not gonna get ding ding ding ding de way
from my goal right now and so that sort
of process this is kind of like the
first time with these with this device
that can just go ding ding ding ding
ding all over us as well as these
laptops that have the ability to
distract us away from it that our
short-term goals and our long-term goals
Michelangelo took four years to sculpt
the Statue of David you know that really
gives you an idea of what I could and
you know there's filmmakers that take
years to make movies and stuff like that
and now if I can't get something done
them the split of a second then I'm then
I'm feeling because anxiety we even
touched on like I meant the mental
health issues you wrote that on your
whiteboard back there the mental health
issues of all this stuff definitely
something that I'm thinking about a lot
recently yeah so what do you think about
all this well I so one thing that
occurred to me once is that like I do
think that well I'll tell you what it
what I think I think that you know we
have an easel and advance management
training course where it like basically
reverse engineer what MIT was teaching
it this really expensive program and all
that stuff and it's really cool to have
the theories of management science but
what occurs to me is that what makes
people win increasingly is having a
healthy mental attitude maybe healthy is
not the right word but a focused mental
attitude it occurs to me this quote from
Bill Gates that's like people tend to
dramatically overestimate what they
could build in a year and underestimate
what they could build in 10 years yes
and so anyway I think the mental health
component is real and I think that the
ability
to basically get away from these like it
the way James Williams in his TED talk
gets into this stuff is like he you know
we tend to think of technology as this
like spotlight like oh I'm just gonna
not use Facebook as much I'm just not
going to check my email as much like
these little miniature small scope
actions but what he's arguing is that we
need to look at the super big picture my
wife is amazing at this she's just like
yo you might want to just get rid of
whole categories of technologies that
don't matter but like okay interesting
question yeah what categories of
technology that don't matter
yeah like so I'll tell y'all James
Williams describes as he says on an
individual level we have to want what we
want to want and I know that's like
pretty meta but it's interesting because
I sometimes feel like do you ever feel
like these platforms and technologies
are steering us into a pathway of the
experience of life that we basically
don't even know if we want know why
totally yeah so I mean I think in that
that that that may brings up the
question what do we want and I feel like
the business models all screwed up
that's why it's led us there well so
let's talk about the business model
because our after all easel is a
business education channel and what
occurs to me is that there are
structural misalignments in many
business models I think for example like
any publicly traded company is
structurally incented to mac to extract
maximum profit from yeah from the
organization who are the extracting
maximum profit from well max revenue
from the consumers lowest wages from the
employees and highest returns for the
shareholders so of those three
stakeholder groups you have employees
customers and shareholders two of the
three of them are structurally getting
squeezed right so it occurs to me that
that is not a healthy ecosystem
long-term and especially when it gets
not just in terms of money but in terms
of
and so in the attention economy thing
how can you align the incentives of the
organization and the stakeholders and
the and the consumers and the investors
and it seems to me like like the the
alignment has to be about serving
something greater than yourself
something that's based on human values
something that's good for the planet and
I'm not sure I'm also not sure if all
these technology companies are created
equal
I kind of feel like Google is good at
managing this stuff better than then
maybe Facebook I really don't trust
Facebook do you have any thoughts on
that Alan do you see any differences
between the way that these big players
in the information economy handle their
their ethics and their approach to this
stuff mmm it's a really good question um
yeah
how many design ethicists are there at
Google or Facebook just as a as a just
trying to do an objective measure on how
many of them are there because that
that's always an important question to
ask is are you actually pairing together
the philosophers and the ethicist with
the computer programmers that are
building the AI because if you're not
then you have a big problem and this is
saying have you ever heard like I know
you're interviewing a lot of people in
this space are there companies or
organizations that are pairing up ethics
and the development of their
technologies that you've you know people
you've interviewed yeah or even people
that are working on specifically like AI
safety and security so they're even the
ones that are going and putting a huge
amount of the Ephesus and the
Philosopher's in with the computer
programmers and so just just that notion
of of ethicists that drastically need to
be in the space of the attention economy
and social media is so important but
again the business model is all screwed
up because if we take a look at you know
Twitter or the Facebook's and what we
see is that we see a business model
that's based on advertising the longer
that you stay on the service the more
advertisements you see and the more
money that company makes so they don't
have an incentive to kick you off the
platform after a couple minutes what
does it do to our brain Allen if we're
like on a platform for like you know
like sometimes with Twitter you kind of
like you just like COO like what does
that do to our brain what's happening
yeah um it's like an unlimited newspaper
I guess as a way to look at it and I
guess that's an analogy for just the
recent history but even I guess pre
printing press it's it's it it's it's it
be like if someone was I guess just
standing next to you and just be able to
just basically tweet with their mouth
out to you just whatever was going on in
civilization that day just not stop and
you could either choose to why does our
brain keep just like wanting to scroll
what's that all about
it's a well at least to the degree that
I understand it's the constant urge for
novelty so we have just an insatiable
appetite for new information but like
new its new one one thing one thing
about that urge for novelty though is
that when you when you realize this the
signal-to-noise ratio of the novelty you
can do things like you can only follow
really smart people that you think are
really important you can do things like
right you'll see first in your Facebook
feeds so you can you can curate your
feeds by by by following specific
content asking to see that content first
getting notifications for that certain
content and then past that anything else
that you really you can find Chrome
extensions besides Stanford's habit lab
like Facebook newsfeed Eradicator which
doesn't even let you see your newsfeed
on the desktop version and you seem to
be going towards this thing of like man
the technologies well you know use the
features in Facebook and Twitter and
LinkedIn or whatever to manage it well
versus like don't do it yeah and there's
another that's a good way to look at a
new there's another way to look at it
which is inbound outbound so you know
Here I am in the center and inbound is
all these messages that I get inbound
and then outbound is all the messages
that I sent out so I keep my inbound on
silent all day every day silent because
I don't want to get distracted from my
focus of what I'm focused on you know
weird though because I kind of feel like
you know I've tried to reduce the amount
of stuff that I share on social media of
course like I'm a media producer so like
I have a lot of content to share but
like sometimes I feel that like it's
kind of a unethical approach for me to
be on social media just sharing all my
stuff and then not receiving and
listening to other people it's kind of
like that person that comes to the party
and just talks too much and you're like
God you shut up
you ever think about that that's a good
way to put it it's so it's not
necessarily that I'm oh that I only go
out bound so let's put it this way
you're you're right where I do end up
going on my like feed and looking at
what other people have posted I totally
end up doing that but just this general
idea of like if you are a node and you
have all these spokes that are coming
into the node and then you choose to
turn off the connectivity that they
can't did to you immediately so if you
were to pay me on messenger I am NOT
going to pay you back right away and
then there's a certain quality
I guess if Elon Musk pings you on
messenger via email you're probably
gonna reply to him versus if you know if
someone else thinks you that is just
trying to be like hey how are you and
you're just like you know I'm making
content right now I can't pay you back
so then then you basically get to pick
so if you're working and then you
realize okay Davis has to send Sally a
message about the content that we're
making then you will go and send Sally a
message so you basically get to be in
control of your
box out box flow rather than other
people being in control of it well one
of the topics of this conversations are
we being controlled and I want to get
into this because I'm kind of passionate
about sociology and basically I have
this feeling that in general most of us
don't make any of the decisions that we
think we are making of our own accord
and that we're really constantly making
decisions as a result of programming
that comes from external factors we all
think that we're so individualistic and
in control of our own stuff in reality
I'm pretty sure that that's almost never
the case and maybe it's in conjunction
with stuff we're saying okay we want to
go over there and then you have some
other external inputs let me be
practical about this so what I mean from
a practical standpoint is like the way
that our brains have habituated because
of smartphones because of social media
because of the messages of the
government we live in a democracy we
have a system where in America we've
devolved a lot of responsibility down to
individual people social pressure status
pressures all these things shape our
decisions and I do think that we're
being controlled in some way but I don't
know if that is unique I feel like
throughout human history human beings
have been controlled by bigger forces do
you think that that do you agree with me
there Allen do you see something
different yeah I'm definitely
calculating the variables that you're
talking about and I'm the general sort
of feeling of not being in control
feels like it's pretty damn real you
feel out of control now
it's like you know Robert Sapolsky talks
about this in this book behave which is
just that throughout the multiple
billions of years of evolution every
sort of genetic expression that's
occurred since then an ever
environmental factor that's occurred
since then to make the humans that we
are today that those are way more in
charge of of us that we are and so we
actually don't have that much control so
he's arguing that from an epoch like
evolution
canary patterns caused us to behave in
certain ways in general yeah yeah
exactly and they taking taking into
account something like the amount of
control that you have over over what you
think like that you're gonna eat or what
you think when you you know when you're
in your dream state or what you think
when you make just any sort of decision
at all that it has a whole lineage of
billions of years of decision making
units not just something that you just
came up with in the moment and then also
in terms of the technology that exists
today and how that's you know how in
control or not we are the attention
economy being being the business model
being about attention and how many
advertisements I can show you it's
actually further pushed social
scientists to figure out how to get you
addicted into receiving as much of the
dopamine as possible over and over again
and clicking go through the lottery
system over and over again I'd like
though we're at an inflection point
honestly I want to read this one one
additional quote here that all right so
this according to a recent Harvard
University study Chinese state
propagandists create four hundred and
forty eight million posts on social
media a year using a technique known as
reverse censorship four hundred and
forty eight million posts a year as one
of the report's authors noted the point
isn't to get people to behave no to
believe or care about the propaganda
it's to get them to pay less attention
to the stories that the government wants
to suppress the idea would be that the
attention economy incent I think that in
in many ways the American political
figures primarily the president has used
distraction a lot I know that this is
something that Russian propagandists use
a lot so like distraction is almost
trying to get us away from the stories
that matter maybe do you see any of that
absolutely but that's actually probably
the the biggest
one of the biggest problems along with
this whole psychometric profiling
distraction mean by psychometric
profiling in the context of what I just
said
so for example the way that I what what
I what I like on Facebook can generate a
average Allen Oxman that if you like
content that's generally liberal then
you'll be pushed more liberal news feed
itll items if you lighting these are
more conservative so it's like
distraction on steroids because you're
put into a bucket and then they're like
cool whatever we think will do best at
distracting you will be pushed to you
yeah yeah and then it gets again and
then it gets kind of worsened by other
organizations that are able to access
this data about you that then can say oh
well because Davis likes this I can then
manipulate the way that he thinks about
the world by pushing an advertisement to
him that doesn't even exist not even a
real thing but I don't think that I've
been noticing too is like there's a lot
of algorithmic stuff is based on
grouping you with other people like the
Financial Times which I've been
subscribed to you for a long time now
they're starting this like chatbot news
feature that's basically like we're
gonna push you the most read stories in
the categories that you seem to like
every day and I don't like these types
of technologies I don't like Spotify
buuza chrec amend or service for example
if anybody likes that sorry but like
basically I don't want to be pushed
things that they think other people like
me would like cuz that keeps me in a
bubble I want my own variant to be
directing the direction of my attention
yep yeah that's good I like that a lot
so this seems like there is a time and
place for things that are recommended
and there is a time and place for doing
things like understanding the complete
opposite of the point of view that yes
hey okay so then one more thought around
distraction real quick is just yeah if
if we're we're approaching an era we've
had dr. Roman imposts key on the show a
couple times one of the
we're the world's leading AI safety and
security researchers and so if you take
a look at the way that we're
transitioning to what are called deep
fakes so you what's the name of the
person you know
dr. Roman Jung Polsky and I can Roman
yon Polsky okay I can link it to you and
so what's what's nuts about this is that
if you just take what this era of deep
fakes and you just take this idea that I
can literally make a computer rendering
of Davis that is completely
indistinguishable from the real Davis
and have him say whatever I want him to
say and then put that onto Twitter and
say I captured Davis saying this then we
have a whole new era of problems that
are going on and this is already being
worked on as in whenever you know anyone
across the planet Trump or who have you
says you know that's fake news that
wasn't me that was a that was a deep
fake then we have a whole new era of
problems that are gonna emerge from that
let me ask you this Alan and I want to
just get kind of personal not like you
know private or anything but like if you
if you to the extent that you can remove
yourself from the pressures of status
and a lot of us have this pressures of
paying bills and stuff you know and you
could say this is what I want to work on
what matters to me what are some of the
things that you think matter apart from
the distractions of all these you know
these things like if you weren't
distracted at all what do you think is
worth the focus you know what's the
myopic things to work on yeah it's a
good question Davis no I'm writing about
this a lot this book about time and
about the human race and I'm writing
about exactly what you described or
should these which are these pressures
that we have in this socio-economic
hierarchy to [ __ ] go up to increase
our upward mobility in there yeah and if
that didn't exist if we didn't have
these pressures
I would likely still be working on
something similar to what I'm working
right now but also at the same time I
bet I would be passing time a little bit
more like if we had that longevity as a
work that like dr. Aubrey de Grey is
doing with extending life so if you can
get your lifespan out to like your how
healthy like how you feel when you're 15
years old if you can hold that feeling
and tell your 200 years old that then I
think things would move a little bit
differently as well you might focus more
time on traveling focus more time on on
just being and like going to the park
and just walking around and enjoying
life falling into love multiple times
just spending more time in love things
like I don't know about the just being
thing it's funny you know because I just
beat a lot and I'm like okay being is
cool um I'm being man I'm being but like
I don't know I got some goals and some
ambition but I want it to be channel in
the right way the only thing I can come
up with that I think is something that
unifies beyond distraction is that you
know if you can help people focus on
creating value for other people then
it's kind of this virtuous cycle I kind
of feel like at the stage that we are in
this attention economy like for example
like the fact that Facebook would prefer
to distract you from what you want to do
so they can make money that is a zero
sum if not a negative sum game because
they're gonna hurt you from them
existing and that's not good but I feel
like if there are things that get you to
focus on doing things for other people
making the world better for future
generations then that's a good thing
that's where you and I align a lot of
our values which is that we care deeply
about impacting society in ways that
make it a better place for future
generations and let's let's let's get
there let's unleash that soul and that
creative spirit in children that are
being birthed in the world
yeah I know you focus a lot on children
it is interesting in the in the era of
social media I feel like one thing that
maybe is coming to an end a little bit
is going to be this idea of a parent a
parochial relationship between
individuals like you know I think the
personal brand for example seeks to
elevate people
above others I am elevated in this area
and it's one thing to say I am an expert
in this area but it's different to say I
am elevated above it and I think that
maybe if we get into this more like
contribution mindset that like what
we're doing is create co-creating
something good then maybe we'll get away
from some of this negative social media
stuff negative technology patterns that
seeks to differentiate us I feel like
maybe there's something there about
being differentiated versus being
contributed and say what like this Lord
impact and I'm sorry I'm rambling here
but this word impact kind of gets me
sometimes impact suggests that there's
something wrong right I am here to make
an impact because there's something
wrong but there's a lot of studies that
show that like people generally they
don't want to be impacted right they
want to elect to partake of something
that they want to be a part of and I
kind of feel like this idea that there's
something wrong is at the root of a lot
of this distraction right like we talked
earlier about these mechanisms of
distracting us you know the Liberals
want to hear this message the
Conservatives want to hear this message
all of this is to tap into this sense of
Rage this sense of oh there's something
wrong everywhere but I'm not sure I'm
not sure that there is that that is the
the path forward yeah you know in this
this this goes really deep to how do we
decide and construct this technology to
maximize human flourishing and we don't
have the answers to that but we we can
definitely start pushing ourselves in
that direction of and we have with what
James wrote and with what he interest on
Harris and Mac Stossel working on what
time well-spent I'm definitely going to
time well spent at i/o and go check out
some of the design techniques that they
are working on regarding fixing a lot of
the way that we that we communicate with
each other in this
in this attention economy so I want to
also talk about for the viewers who are
tuning in with us is that it's also just
about like the nature of advertising and
marketing we have a big marketing
community here at asel and I kind of
feel like this idea of the extractive
company is coming to an end a little bit
I noticed for example that like a lot of
companies that were like I think
coca-cola is a good example there was a
time in the past when the coca-cola CEO
said good I think about every day how
can I get coca-cola into somebody's
belly right now
you know coca-cola was a treat it was a
candy that you had as a treat and the
fact that people know this about brands
means that these companies that don't
act with ethics I think that they're
gonna hurt themselves and I think that
as smarter and smarter as as education
is more and more pervasive that these
companies that don't use your attention
judiciously are going to lose you I'm
thinking about leaving Facebook which is
ironic because I actually am at Facebook
Ads guy and I like do a lot of Facebook
ads but I would use it for ads but like
not be on it myself which is kind of
weird but um I think I think they've
lost my trust and I entrust is
fundamental yeah absolutely
super fundamental well is there anything
that you wanted to share particularly
with us Alan about you know your
thoughts on mental health and and and
all the stuff because I know this is
really your area well one one thing
about mental health I think we don't
really think about too much is just what
is going on with comparing ourselves to
other people rather than comparing
ourselves to who were yesterday
think we really learn a lot by just
looking at ourselves objectively in the
mirror this sort of process of like
self-knowledge Who am I looking at
myself in the mirror being like how did
i do yesterday regarding my goals and
what do I want with future offering what
do I want in the next week what I wanted
the next month in the next year how do I
build those things into the world and
what we're doing on social media a lot
of the time as we're seeing someone post
picture of themselves traveling to Ollie
or whatever and then we go oh my gosh I
wish I was in Bali and then we have this
process of somebody posting a picture of
them with some materialistic object like
a watch or a car or a new house or
whatever and then we go I want that too
when we can get our skin ourselves in
that process versus the alternative to
that which i think is really powerful
which is that I'm blessed to be here
right now
breathing this air with this roof over
my head with this amount of food in my
fridge and that I have these goals to
get further in life but that I also
understand how to be grateful for what I
have today and it when was the last time
that you saw someone post on social
media something some sort of of sadness
or some sort of despair that they've had
in their life and how they overcame that
a lot of people aren't choosing to not
talk about things like things like that
and we're just it's like one mechanism
of control is definitely this
materialism that you're talking about
and these in there's a certain
relationship between the advertising
platforms they need to have a culture
where we accept the materialism because
that is this thing that they're selling
to the advertisers that hey these people
will respond to your materialism stuff
and then so we're going to advertise
there and then it goes through and then
we buy it and now the system is enforced
and I yeah I I and I think that that's
part of the ethical thing too like I
don't trust Louie Vuitton for example I
don't think Louie Vuitton has my best
interest in mind so I think that there's
a relationship between the comparative
thing that you brought up and the
attention economy because if we kind of
start paying attention to things that
are more virtuous then maybe we won't
like they we maybe we wouldn't even
receive the ads of the things that are
materialistic because the platforms
would recognize that we don't like that
stuff yeah and there's a lot there's a
long way to go with also just getting it
this
type of understanding of dematerializing
to young children so that when they're
born into the world that they are not
going absolutely nuts for all of the
newest and-and-and what do you what
would you want would you want the newest
sort of technology in her face like the
like the newest sort of augmented
reality headsets or would you want to
have you know a bunch of different
persons like that like that sort of
mentality like which one which one which
one if you had to pick and and and from
and for me it's almost it's it's very
obvious what would probably be more
important for kids but then again
someone like you know maybe Connie are
the designers that Louie Vuitton might
say that oh well if you get a child to
look at all these different t-shirts or
purses or whatever that then they become
a better designer themselves there's
many different variables that go into
this argument across I love the way
you're focusing on kids though I mean
for people that have kids if you know
when you think about this stuff with
kids Alan what are some of the things
that you think about with the attention
economy and kids I know that this is an
area of your of your focus and it's
definitely a way to ensure that hard to
work for future generations you know if
you're helping kids have better mental
health for example that's good yeah yeah
it's the the way that the children are
now born into the world that will not
know what it's like to grow up without a
smartphone they're born into the world
with even now kids that are born today
will never drive a car all this
different kind of stuff and so if you
give us a kid a smartphone you when
they're two years old I'm gonna really
be paying attention that's around the
age of two is when a lot of this initial
like neural infrastructure is really
being built and and solidified for you
over time the sort of foundational
neural architecture and so if you do
things like play candy crush on your
phone at that age should
arguments to be made about you know
motor cortex and the ability to
recognize patterns and sure but at the
same time
what is that teaching them versus if
they're watching videos about the
evolution of humanity or about the
evolution of technology or about
futurism and stuff like that when
they're 2 4 6 8 10 12 so so it's really
really about about figuring out what the
kid likes and helping be a catalyst for
what the kid likes well if we were to
wrap up a little bit one thing that I
want to focus that I want to share with
the people watching and thanks for being
here with us and I see if Tarun made a
comment here he said does it lead to
being compromised for a better life I
wonder yeah I don't know what you mean
they're true but basically as we wrap up
I mean I think that one tool that I want
to introduce one one thought point that
I want to leave people with and I want
you to comment on this Allen is like I
think that we need to remember to focus
on long term things it's a good tool
we're like what do I want to build over
the next 10 years versus what do I want
to build over the next week it's good
because it seems like it's easier in the
attention economy the problem is that we
get micro distracted to oblivion you
know we're like what okay micro
distraction and we just like oh it's
just a little bit just a little micro
distraction it's just 10 minutes on
Facebook it's just 20 minutes on
Facebook but that stuff stacks and over
the long term now you spent so much of
your time being distracted that you
didn't do the things that mattered over
the long term I think very few people
would say what do I want what do I want
to do in 10 years oh I wanna over the
over 10 years you know I want to get
more likes on Facebook no way so I don't
know do you think that's a good tool to
kind of keep us focused on the good
stuff Allen yeah you make a really good
point
it's you look at you looking like a week
from now and you're like what are my
goals over the next couple days so I can
achieve my goals in the week and then
you're talking about no one no one says
I want to get more likes on Facebook
over the next 10 years you want to build
something
something found meaningful for you and
meaningful for other people something of
value for the world to really be able to
figure out how to focus on that is is
super important to do throughout one's
life that's why you're building ezel so
I was building simulation yeah you know
that's why I mean to create the
infrastructure for an undergraduate
degree that cost 500 bucks it's gonna
take us you know four years and but you
know whatever I don't have anything
better to do if I could create an
alternative to college it cost 500 bucks
and save much people a bunch of money
and then help them start their careers
without debt I'm in for that you know
yeah great work with these own super
excited yeah well and thank you for
being with us this morning Alan I really
appreciate you getting up I know you're
on the west coast it's early for you and
I appreciate your time yeah this has
been a lot of fun Davison but it would a
great brain boost topic this was a
really good one yeah I feel like it's
squishy you know it's it's it's hard to
really get deep and tangible into it but
I I wanted to bring it up because I see
this you know a lot of people in the
ezel community are looking for ways to
advance their careers and I think that
one of the area's that's most ignored is
mental health
thinking patterns ways of looking at
things that are data driven but you know
like it's this it's there's just so much
to the infrastructure of your brain your
thought patterns that matter when it
comes to career success it's not always
just these like little tactical things
though I share this thing on LinkedIn
with hashtags like that's just not going
to do it all the time you know yep and
an interesting thought for your audience
the way that we kind of you know
commingled this this this brain boost
together is that you know Eagle does you
know the $500 undergraduate degree of
the future and you know simulation does
a lot of these thought-provoking
conversations and questions with these
different diverse global leaders on
media streams so I think that there is
an interesting synergy there and you
know to be able to send each other our
followings I think is a very synergistic
so it's good stuff you know totally all
right we're
to wrap up the brain boost thank you for
being here I'll see you next Thursday at
10 a.m. Central Time
see you later Alan bye guys thanks to
nian see there's